so I'm going to present a functional
pattern toolkit for a data set which was
introduced in a version 10 this is based
on our work at the VA San Diego and
we're going to illustrate and University
of California of San Diego's well and
we're going to illustrate some of the
methods with real data wherever possible
although it's kind of limited at this
particular stage ok so we're studying
how in clinical situations are in real
hospitals how computers are being used
by doctors and our patients and doctors
communicate you know with the medium of
the computer in the room ok so that's a
scenario but really what I want to show
is that these methods is kind of trying
to transcend the specific application
areas here ok and we're also involved in
IIT we design and or studies have been
going on for about five years now and
our support comes from combination of
National Institute of Health and also
the Veterans Administration have a
research office and we're also involved
with the VA in IT redesign so in other
words like re-engineering health IT ok
which i think is a really good
opportunity for a Wolfram to get
inserted in there ok so in by the way so
our studies which all been done with
Mathematica sort of like the centerpiece
of the analytics part of it have been
ranked very very highly by both NIH MVA
like literally like one or two
percentile which is uh you know you know
the funding levels have been going down
and down so that's a very good thing ok
so we use primarily in the interest of
of budget and time we're so constrained
that we basically could not even afford
the DBA and we just decided just put
everything on the cloud this is you know
this happened like in the past couple of
years so we were kind of rushed to do
this so we're using a collaborative
cloud based approach to store all our
data now we respect to the previous talk
you know this is like small data we're
not putting up like an enterprise
database this is primarily just data
that has been captured and we're
analyzing it okay so it's not as if we
have like data entry tasks or they need
to be very granular in terms of like
data entry but nevertheless so we're you
know the opportunities that too we can
leverage the web file system so we're
using google drive for example to store
all our data so why not leverage their
our article file system that
already being given to us and you know
web link data of course is part of that
and we're not using sequel at all at
least for my purposes we also have to be
open I'm just one person doing analytics
we also have you some of my colleagues
are using r and python for example so we
have to collaborate and we have multiple
format but it's still really basic stuff
right we have sensors that spread out
CSV files or then we can convert them to
google spreadsheets which are co
editable which is a gigantic leap
forward everybody can simultaneously
edit any piece right so this is a very
agile approach something goes wrong so
like again like instead of having a
sequel a schema which is predefined we
really don't have time for that and
really things change as we go along so
that it's much faster to do this way of
course you run into errors you're going
to run into exceptions we handle that an
analysis I'm and then one aspect of that
is really because we have to get
everybody to understand the data we have
literally like coders interns people who
don't understand data necessarily who
take a long time to explain hey well you
have to you know there would have to be
caught up in the sequel situation where
the sequel would not work for them but
instead we basically have to have
something that kind of is both machine
readable and human readable at the same
time okay so I want to stress that we're
not doing any kind of big data
everything fits on one machine we're
dealing with about ten gigabytes of data
from different sensors the bulk of the
data is a time series type of things so
it's not like it's it's large but it's
the variety really that gets you okay so
we're not doing anything in terms of
like velocity we're not dealing with
bandwidth type of issues those guys to
keep in mind those types of limitations
here some of our sensors come from you
know we deal with a variety of different
data so it's you can call the semi
structure we have numeric data that
comes that would be like a natural thing
in any kind of study text data so it's
like unstructured you know patient
record type of stuff like I said time
series from my tracking from you know we
have connecting the room we try to see
people's emotions so there's a time
motion studies really okay okay
okay so mathematica 10 really brought in
lots of innovations in terms of like
data analysis yeah I've been working
with Mathematica since version 2 for
about 15-20 years and it was it's a
struggle to handle multiple types of
data and index time and so on right so
just going from version 9 to version 10
has made a huge difference in terms of
or code base I basically like threw away
most of the application and API stuff
that it did before in favor of the
version 10 data set support because it's
just so much more compact and you know
if you have compact code it's a lot
easier to read it's a lot easier to
maintain and and you constantly going to
be adapting in any way functional
meaning that you want to do as much
stuff in line through compositions of
queries and query makes that possible
this is my personal belief that if you
can avoid helper functions to any degree
of pot it's not really possible one
hundred percent at a time but if you can
avoid it in a data analytic situation
you want to have the code to be a
streamlined as possible so that you
don't have any reference dependencies to
get back and clean up like I said it's
not always possible but to me it's
almost like if you can make the language
become a scripting language in a sense
you've gone a long way towards up making
your job easier and so so one of the
main things is that rapid development is
really you can test the code on on a
small number or a subset of your data
right because you're going to be in an
exploratory mode to begin with there's
tons of stuff will clean up there's tons
of normalization to do even before you
get to the statistics or data
visualization of things like that so you
can test in a very small set and data
set makes it very easy as i'm going to
show you to then expand it to your full
data set okay so that's one of the
gigantic things so some of the functions
that are associated that came out in
like number 10 in version 10 in addition
to data set really the Association data
structure is really like like the heart
of the system let's say because it's a
it doesn't look like much it's almost
like a key value list but underlying it
is a very sophisticated a hash tree
implementation of that and then you have
all these operators like merge and write
composite you know composition was there
in the language I think since version 1
but now you can kind of right from left
to right and just keep going composing
the language like that operator forms
and name slots are also very big thing
they'll make the language a lot more
readable basically I think that if we
can make operator forms for the entire
language you can make the language
almost readable like a human language in
a sense okay okay so here's some
examples and these are just I'm just
give me two because we have google
spreadsheets and they're really just
like on your local desktop when your mom
google drive there literally just like a
couple lines of JSON it's just that URL
essentially right so you have to
dereference the URL so we fetch all our
data from online okay so Google's
basically taking care of your
synchronization for you which is one of
the aspects that databases are used for
so in a sense we're cutting that out
that middle step there okay so these are
just some utility functions to tell you
that you can export a Google spreadsheet
as a CSV for example okay all right now
so here's an example of some of the data
that we have none of it really fits on
the screen but so here's an example of a
query so we start with a data index
which is just a linear list of things
it's called visit data in this
particular case I've wrote a function
called key group by which is the natural
dual to group by and I'll show it later
I think think I have it so you can see
that you can sort of cut out a lot of
the slot you know actually numerical
slot in this particular case so this is
a query this entire query basically
takes a long list of files and
essentially this is the output this is
how it's actually structured so what you
see here is all the different types of
sensors that we have okay so you can
seem a combination of different things
EMR means a electronic medical records
so these are human coders go through and
they figure out what what are the people
actually typing on what what it is see
on the screen based on video review so
we have combination of multiple things
when you do scientific studies you have
to have multiple coders so you can do
agreements type stuff these are most of
the times time series so you have like
synchronization parameters that are also
handled in google spreadsheets
essentially and this is the actual these
are just references to the data files so
each one of these data files would
really be either a CSV file so we'll be
in you know in boonton secretly would be
like a separate table for each one of
these cue dots these are just our
identifiers and you know we have
hundreds of these seven years ago so you
see about 100 per that's about
sample size so it's really really the
sample size of this study that's the
unit of measurement of the study is like
the visit meaning the doctor and the
patient are in the same room and you
captured them for a while for about a
half an hour let's say so that would be
like Q 0 0 1 would be one patient one
doctor but because you have all these
multiple sensors that's you can see the
blow-up is based really on that okay so
even though it's happening equals 100 it
turns out it's about 10 gigabytes worth
of data just because of this okay so
what I really want to emphasize is
before this this is a lot longer than
three lines of code okay okay okay so up
so again like I mentioned like you want
to leverage cloud services wherever
possible here's the example of key group
by which is you know it's not a big deal
i just want to mention that bike tool
kit i really mean that you can write a
lot in just like one or two lines of
code okay an operator a form makes it
easier to sort of like go left to right
now i'm not going to explain these
pieces it took me about a year or so to
sort of figure out and when I first
started I was a C++ C and C++ programmer
and you learn one way of dealing with
code took about five years of transition
to start thinking in terms of like
functional style and pattern matching
and once you do it like that you can see
the advantages it's hard to go back all
right so this is functional style so
it's not as if you just you can't just
no Mathematica coming from a different
background and expect to understand this
there are even people in Stack Exchange
or like major experts and define some of
these queries hard to read but with a
little bit of practice you can actually
develop your own very quickly okay so
here's an example what you do so key
group by essentially remember those cue
files that I told you before each one is
a visit so here there's no data this is
all metadata this is just telling you
what's grouped together by what so here
we have these these are the doctors so
one doctor might have multiple visits
the number of visits varies so here are
we group them together and this is the
query this is it including the
visualization the paneling and grouping
all these things together and then
further you can iterate this so not only
are the visits group to the doctor but
the doctors then our group by for
example specialty okay so here you have
a PC piece of primary doctor GIS
pulmonologist and so on okay we have
multiple ways of grouping data we also
have by sight VA versus UCSD they're
different hospitals and so on okay
but again to me is when you present this
type of stuff to colleagues is a lot
easier to do then if you just have some
flat table it really is to have this
kind of hierarchy okay so your keys are
really like the handles and you've gone
beyond the sequel world right sequel is
all about these relational tables that
are two-dimensional but as soon as you
have keys you introduce these new shapes
essentially in your data now here's a
couple of variation of I'm not going to
spend too much time on this because
after i did this i realize that there is
a built-in key value apply the basically
does similar to this except that a you
know my handler gives you this key so
you don't have to write the key each
time that you do this all right but not
a big deal it's just to show you the
keys and value can serve you can mix
them together think of it as a two by
two matrix you have the inputs the keys
and values and sometimes you need to
combine them together okay and I'll show
you some example of that so these are I
want to stress these are just one liners
that do a lot of work very reusable
here's another one you have you have a
relational table and you basically do a
key pop you take one of the primary keys
essentially and you extract it out here
are some examples this is how you would
do a normal relational table and then
you pop the key and now the keys are
essentially one and two there were like
ID basically ID 1 and 2 right and then
you can reinsert it ki push and now it's
back in there okay so you can go back
and forth between these two modes
sometimes one is better than the other
and depends on the purpose okay now
here's my favorite one actually I
submitted this to the one-line
competition so this is a one-line
recursive query that basically can d
serialize file lists so let's say the
what I have here I think I submitted the
entire thing so let's say you have a
file names given to you and I'm you can
use whatever you want to think of
submitted just Google Drive you want to
index all of google drive right you get
this flat list of paths okay so once you
split them apart by the path components
then essentially you can apply this tree
and this query then we'll give you a
nested association where each of the
path components becomes the prefix for
that level of the association ok so now
I actually had an argument a stack
exchange with the inventor of
association leonid sure friend
thought that this would not really scale
up that this would be not be a like a
good way to actually create that DC
realization but sometime timing studies
suggest that this is actually linear in
the leaf count so I think that really
speaks to the efficiency of the
underlying Association okay so this is
the input and this is the output and
it's normalized so you don't actually
see the the data set formatting for this
but basically you see that your root
directory Google Drive so this is the
key for 41 Association but then you have
sub associations so now you can
essentially like dereference just by
typing in you know Tilda google drive
whatever you want or you can use all or
spans and things of that nature so you
can go at this level so what's the
advantage of this is that now you can
see it from one line you can actually
handle arbitrarily depth trees just with
this one line of code I find this really
fascinating this is possible so let me
just give you a so query actually works
with any mathematical expression however
it generates a temporary data set okay
which is them then it's a thrown away
but in other words there's an internal
like types definition in data set so
there's a little bit of an overhead
involved in that but you can basically
apply query to any expression okay these
are no big deal just again somewhere
things too sore to say like if you have
an association and you just want to like
tally things of course you can use the
built-in tally and there's actually
other the functions that can kind of do
similar things but again my point is
that you know it's I think of these
things in my sleep when I go jogging I
can think because there's one line of
code you can kind of keep everything in
memory if this is a longer query you
can't do that you know it becomes kind
of it's a chore to it becomes like a
puzzle that you kind of have fun trying
to solve normalized by let's say you
have a list you have to branch off to
find out what's the total for that
numerical list but then you want to
normalize all the individual entries by
that total you sort of have to branch
into these two steps right you have to
sort of so you can see like a nested
query here there's the original I could
have put identity here and then here's a
particular function that the user passes
and then you have to merge them together
now this is actually pretty bad i found
some easier ways to sort of using
replace and pattern matching
to put them back together but again this
one particular function you can apply to
any association by the way I have an API
that's i'm just showing about like ten
twenty percent of what's here but
they're all about like one or two lines
of code each one okay okay so here's one
that's a little bit more sophisticated
quantile Association you have a you have
an association and then you want to
essentially group them to where they are
in the statistics are you in the top
twenty percent are you in the bottom
twenty percent of the of the entire
Association so this is basically it so
you have well of course this is a couple
a little bit more work just because of
the way that quantiles work their
intervals and so on right so so you have
a function here to you notice by the way
like every time that you have to
separate input arguments here you have
this is operator form essentially this
is the it operates on this but this
becomes the parameter essentially the
quantile so you can change the parameter
of the quantile steps essentially so
here's an example of how you would
operate you have this data and this is
the NASA this is called the NASA TLX
it's basically like how stressed are you
doing the visits and workflow type of
survey so these doctors fill in these
surveys and of course we hear their
bintu cuantas and then we color them
according to where they are so I think a
blue there in the bottom quartile gray
is like the center like fifty percent
and then the blue or red are like the
top twenty percent we you know those are
all just parameters you can change and
what this shows you is very quickly i
was able to convince my colleagues that
look at this dr. 07 regardless of the
patients the patients would be one row
each each patient will be one row and
then each item of the TLX a survey is a
column and just by showing you this you
can see that dr. 07 is never stressed
every visit every item is either you
know normal or below stress level
whereas if you have some other doctors
like dr. tan gastroenterology pretty
much every visit their stress about
something right now what I'm saying is
like this is a very complex and
efficient way to communicate with people
this graphical language now we
underlying this or numbers right but
what I'm saying is like just one extra
step later you can convert these numbers
or something but again these are all
keyed so you have the keys that are
already available to you there's no
point
you don't add them later I used to
basically you have to like in version 9
you have to kind of like fetch all the
keys and put them together here they're
already there the functional aspect is
you're just manipulating the values the
keys are invariant okay so they're
already grouped for example okay so
that's an advantage of doing this kind
of stuff and people didn't know about
this stuff before that let's just use
the TLX scores raw no you have to Center
them by the individual doctor okay so
very nice way to communicate the results
yeah okay here's another version of this
this is probably lamer than the previous
version but you can this is the standard
data set formatting so you can see here
you can just rescale basically like a
word cloud type of situation but you can
build these dashboards very quickly now
each one of these are items and so on I
don't want to take too much time but
again it's the fact that functionally
you're just affecting the values but all
the keys are already synchronized okay
this is 11 out of 14 files here's one
that's a little bit more involved so you
know a lot of stuff is baby steps but
when you get into time series analysis
that's that becomes a lot more
complicated because now you've got
synchronization issues the timestamps
are not necessarily reliable you've got
to convert them into intervals of time
values and so on but here's an example
where based on the clickstream analysis
we've combined the mouse activity which
is human coded based on videos with the
keyboard activity and I think that's
about he'd it here and what I want to
strap what's functional about this this
is the query and what's functional about
it is that I'm not telling the system
the coordinates of where to put things
okay I rely a lot on things like row
column grid in these types of which
don't have parameters if you were to
insert things into a graphic then you
have to specify coordinates but the
coordinates might change you have to you
know there's new things that you have to
insert so from a functional point of
view I just let Mathematica do as much
of the work as possible like that TLX
you know I don't specify exactly where
to put it and if you do it like a screen
resize everything is pretty much elastic
okay so i think that's another aspect of
the functional approach so just to show
off their you know we show we can tag
pretty much like all the activity that
happens we can do time of task analysis
so you know all these timestamps they're
not
the wrong times times that the sensors
give you these are like the duration of
how long did it take somebody to went
through our medication entry to a
computer for example well again you have
time objects and you just subtract the
time objects you know yeah a little bit
of scaling to do in terms of time but
again very very quick compared to
version 9 version I to handle time
series was a monster and now it's like
really really approachable so this gives
you a combination but this is like the
not that it's big deal but basically
like the black are like the keystrokes
and every the white frames are like the
mouse activity so basically from this we
were able to show even though all the
datas masked that doctors always enter
manually some numbers that are already
in the in the computer and we're very
interested in this issue of like the
data too redundant then the workflows
redundant you're fetching some data
that's already in the computer why are
you typing it in again so we were able
to show to this click stream analysis
that they're looking on one screen
reading some information on the screen
and then typing it in which can cause
problems but in any case it's
inefficient okay so I just these tools
it again like when most of my colleagues
are at medical doctors or people without
a lot of like data background and if I
were just to give them some either raw
statistics or some kind of like tables
it just never works it just it's not
really convincing this stuff is
basically the raw data and by the way
like when I forward this stuff to my
colleagues at the VA they pretty much
give it to their superiors and they say
like hey here's this guy's in San Diego
who know what they're doing and I and I
can't tell them what tools i use on
everything but it's really not me it's
just the tools themselves up make it a
lot easier to do the sort of stuff okay
so just please keep in mind these are
just like a few lines of code each okay
starting from the raw data almost okay I
think I did this one or just the wrong
sorry alright this is one of my I'm
doing my own project here just to show
you that you can take you know you have
a bunch of data here like in this case I
wanted to do this visualization just to
show that the timeline plot right now
doesn't really have a layout engine so
the labels all kind of clash if you have
too many labels so I just wanted to do
something that kind of spreads out the
labels when they're too close together
for example over here okay so this is
just you just add a parameter and you
try to space them out as much as
possible
but this is it this isn't this is
basically from the raw data this do this
okay and i think i can actually get it
even a shorter you know I built this
baby like a year ago i'm still learning
the system and every time I can get it
like ten percent smaller ten percent
smaller and so on alright so yeah so I'm
very close to the end here ok so I just
wanted to talk about future need you
know unfortunately I can't talk about
every function that we build and we
constantly build new ones anyway right
but I just wanted to say it so they data
set tremendous tool what I wish is I do
a lot of like exploratory stuff where I
need to know the shape of the data
basically right after we index it let's
say and find out any kind of exceptions
and so on what I would really like to
have is some sort of tool that lets you
do that momentarily so like let's say I
want to you know you mathematica already
has openers that you can open and close
but I don't want to like programming
that into like every data set so I would
like to have some sort of remote control
where basically you know you have a key
you know like a touchscreen let's say
and you just open it basically momentary
like open up that key and you see the
values and then when you release it it
just goes back to just the key okay so
now these tools are available this is
from apple logic pro which is a autio
tool basically the ipad is the remote
control so you see of course it's still
you know you can still read the sliders
and so on but you're actually
manipulating what's going on on the main
screen which is the mac here and i think
something similar could be done for data
set because i really spend i don't know
thirty forty percent of my time just
figuring out what where the data is and
you know word branch how does it branch
out and we're kind of merge things and
where the missing values what can be
like it thrown out and so on okay so a
tool like data that would make it much
more real time rather than right now
what I do is you know i'll type in the
query but then i have to delete the
query because i wasn't really interested
in that I just want to explore data okay
alright so then we need functional
interoperability or at least it would be
nice without cloud apps not only just
Google for example right now we can read
from google and we can write to google
spreadsheets but we can try to like a
specific cell or a range of cells right
and but those tools are coming like
smartsheet that you can embed URL so you
basically have a version link data just
from using spreadsheets right so i think
that we can if you improve
interoperability with this
the days of sequel are pretty much gone
because you can do everything inside the
rear and then I just wanted to say that
the we're trying to install Mathematica
on the VA networks they told us know at
the local level anyway because there's
all sorts that you can see this is just
like a fraction of the types of security
measures that we have to like abide by
and if we can you know the data security
and data privacy there are two separate
issues but they're sort of related if we
can handle that I think that might be a
wave where Mathematica can actually be
run on the v8 network so you need things
like secure storage the data when it so
it has to be encrypted they already have
encryption but they don't trust it so
you have to have these actual layers on
top now when i import it I don't want to
constantly do that and encrypt decrypt
so key management authentication and
those types of things if they can be the
more transparent you can make them if
you can make them like one function as
per the Wolfram philosophy to integrate
everything could potentially get over
these types of hurdles and I believe
that's it for now